il est un jardin à l'intérieur duquel on
cultive les souvenirs la tradition des
plantes médicinales un patrimoine que
françois thibert tisaneurs préserve sur
son terrain il pousse des plantes
endémiques indigènes et exotiques comme
la loi et sa mère
attention la souche de la lhouest doit
avoir au moins quatre ans pour
développer ses propriétés médicinales le
à 900 mètres d'altitude la loi et pousse
un peu dans les eaux comme dans les bas
là nous voient un joli pied de lampe
haut-conflent ory donc beaucoup en bon
pour utiliser utilise à l'école est
finie fleury jolies fleurs jaunes qui
sont au bout de 3e année donc que ça
utilise dans il coupe la feuille là et
utilise ça pour
cicatriser les bobos cicatriser les
plaies fait attention à halloween juge
jaune qui coule qu'il faut pas trop trop
se mettre sur la peau ou utiliser parce
que c'est ça peut faire des petits
problèmes
j'utilise aussi pour les brûlures ont
pouffé la cuisine ou bien mon à brûler
ou limpide à l'ouest sous la main ou peu
coupe alliés laisse couler ça et prendre
épluchez voilà et puis passer dessus
comme ça vraiment la coupe et de trois
jours dans la troupe et petit coupé en
rien du tout mais la loi est bien aidé à
moins pour cicatriser
la fusion de la panne a aidé à nice nous
a bien mangé là et il va boire ça juste
après pour bien digérer voilà le petit
teaser n'est pas née alice à nice bien
mélanger la peut rajouter un petit peu
dangereux des dents il fera pas de mal
voilà il ya cinq six personnes navarre
la dose pour 5 6 personnes nous à mettre
ça dans un petit récipient l'impôt versé
là dessus de l'eau que la boîte de soupe
chaude seule bonne on va laisser ça
voilà la plante ne commencent à changer
de couleur la voix bien et ça commence à
être parfumée aussi on sent la bonne
tisane